foreign
all right so how much is this adding up
to do you understand this is adding up
well that's one side we gotta go on the
other side
there's exact prices of how much you
paid she has 10 15 000 worth of gold are
you aware you have to pay Duty on gold
Duty here
you have to pay Duty on these items all
right you already paid access but that's
irrelevant to us you have to pay duty to
the US government when you purchase
anything you know what tell me what uh
and receipts from all over the place yep
some American receipts are also so make
sure you're all thankful mom I do this
every day I know exactly what I'm
looking for so but I want to make sure
we'll make sure before you leave out I
want it to be fair it's always going to
be fair ma'am
all right we're gonna move on to the
bags so you did declare 6 000 in clothes
and the new clothes that you are
declaring are in there right yeah
no I want to make sure I have all my
jewelry otherwise I have to complain
well everything's recorded so you can
file a complaint if you think something
is missing I have to check it out yeah
so you're declining six thousand right
thousand dollars because Laboratories
for my daughter and my meat because of
the wedding yeah and then we have more
here
okay but you have to declare things yes
the right way if there is a failure to
declare yeah the government can seize
these items
okay so I am very familiar with I've
been I'm a university okay but you
didn't declare everything
because I go back and forth okay but did
you ever pay Duty you're supposed to be
here like this I declare it I pay taxes
on okay where here when I pay my overall
tax okay no that's irrelevant this is US
Customs and you have to pay Duty here
okay okay so I'm gonna make the
calculation
so the clothes you did Claire you were
doing good but then we have a lot of
items missing so on those items you're
gonna have to pay a penalty the items
you did clerk is going to be 506 the
penalty on the other items is five
thousand six hundred dollars
so I have to ask are you gonna pay it or
yes I am okay plus I go there every year
her penalty was pretty hefty but people
who want to bring in 10 15 000 worth of
gold are going to get penalized and she
decided to pay and she walked out of
here with her stuff yeah
tough cookie
[Music]